好首先点击进来之后呢
各位看到的就是我们公文制作系统的一个版面
那各位可以看到我们的画面非常的简单
好干净而且有很多颜色非常的漂亮
那我们刚刚有提到了我们的公文制作系统呢
是采一个女子化的方式来进行呈现的
那各位在办理公文之前啊
我们可以看到我们只要把滑鼠呢
移到相对应的栏位
他出现一个白色的小手之后呢
就可以直接点击来进行编辑
例如像我点了暂号保存年线之后呢
就会带出一个暂号设定的部分
那点击进来之后呢
我们承卖人员就要先去选择我们
这一份公文要使用的一个分类号
那分类号在下方这边
如果我们的分类号很多的话呢
下面就会有页数
我们可以去进行切换
那找到我们要使用的这个分类号之后
点击它
然后接着再输入我们的暗示号
那系统就会帮我们把
这个分类号给带入
又或者呢
我们可以直接在上面
去做一个搜寻的动作
除了用点选之外
如果说我们分类号很多的话呢
也可以直接在这边进行输入
输入完成之后呢
再按确定
这样子系统就会帮我们
把这个分类号给带入了
那这边呢
补充说明一下
就是我们的分类号
我们使用过的分类号呢
它就会显示在最上面
好 所以如果我们比较常用的一些分类号呢
我们点个几次之后呢
它就会排序在前方
让各位可以快速的去进行点选
好 那分类号选完之后呢
接着可以看到是我们的一个学校的一个全弦
我这边点击之后呢
都可以去选择
好 接着右侧这边看到的是
我们个人的一个联络的资讯
那下方呢
这边是我们的发文日期
以及发文字号的部分
系统都会自动的进行代入
再来呢
是数别以及密等的部分
各位可以依照需求呢
来进行
来这边进行点击
做编辑
各位可以看到
我们只要滑鼠移过来
出现白色的小手之后呢
就可以进行点击
再来是附件的部分
如果说有附件需要进行夹带的话呢
这边就可以进行夹带
那这边呢
让各位看一下
就是我们夹在附件的话呢
这边的附件月签呢
是我们的发文附件
就是我们的公文
如果要进行发文有附件的话呢
我们就是夹在在发文附件
那如果说今天这个附件呢
是不需要跟这公文一起发出去的
它是参考附件的话呢
我们就可以点到这个参考附件的月签
来进行夹在
那后面呢
有提供像是参考连结
或者是一欄表的部分
好
那附件的夾带方式呢
我们点击进来之后呢
就可以直接点击这个新增档案
接着呢去找到
我们要夾带的复件之后呢
再点选开启
系统就会帮我把这个复件的资料给带入了
各位可以看到下方这边
那如果我们要看它的总表的话呢
就可以点击后面的一欄表
好
这个是复件的夾带方式
那复件夾带除了是点选新增档案
之外呢也可以直接用拖曳的方式哦
可以用拖曳的方式
我们来示范一次
让各位看一下
尼路像我今天想要夹在这个课程表进来的话呢
我们就可以直接找到我们的档案之后
找到档案之后呢
直接用拖翼的方式
拖到我们的栏位底下
再等一下
这个功能我等下确认一下
我们除了用新增档案之外
也可以直接用拖曳的方式
把档案拖到下方这边放开之后
就可以直接新增我们的附件了
那如果说我们今天这个附件
是新增错了的话
我们就可以直接点击后方的删除功能
把它删掉
那如果说我们想要修改它这个里面的说明的文字的话呢
我们就可以点击这个编辑的图案
编辑的图示这边呢就可以进行修改
那修改完成之后呢再点选勾勾的图示
那这样子我们的说明呢就修改完成了
那如果说我们想要把这个说明的文字
再入到上方的附件说明栏位的话呢
我們就可以點擊上方的這個
這個箭頭的圖示
各位可以看到我們下方的說明文字
就會帶入到上面的
附件說明的欄位囉
那我們這邊都操作完成之後呢
再點選確定
各位就可以看到我們這邊
就會有一個附件的說明
然後右側這邊的文稿總管呢
也可以看到我們所夾帶的附件
就會顯示在這邊
那也可以點擊這個附件
我們來進行瀏覽
好 那我们的附件呢
除了从我们的附件栏位进行夹带之外呢
各位可以看到上方工具列这边
也有一个回文针的图示
点击进来之后呢
我们系统也会开出一个附件管理的一个画面
也可以进行附件的夹带
那除了我们的栏位还有上面工具列之外呢
各位可以看到我们的左侧栏位提示工具这边
栏位提示工具这边呢
有一个附件的功能
点击进来之后呢
这边也可以附件
进行附件的夹带哦
所以我们有三个地方可以夹带附件
那各位呢可以依照各位
射手的方式
进行设定就可以了哦
那接下来呢
是我们的必田蓝位之一的竹子
那只要把滑鼠移到竹子
冒号后方呢
点击一下
各位可以看到游表在闪
那这边呢就可以进行我们的内容的输入
输入完成之后呢
那这边要跟各位说明一下
就是我们的竹子的栏位啊
它这个是不可以进行半行的
如果说我们的竹子比较长呢
各位不用担心
就只要把我们的文字
直接输入完就可以了
系统会自动的把我们进行换行
所以我们的主持栏位是不可以换行的喔
把文字直接打完就可以了
那接下来呢
各位可以看到下方的说明的栏位
说明的栏位呢
如果说我们今天说明只有一段的话呢一样直接把花鼠移到说明帽号的后方直接打上我們的文字就可以了那如果說我們今天說明是需要換行的話
他分項的話呢
各位只要把滑鼠移到說明冒號的後方點擊一下
接著再按Enter鍵
這時候呢
系統就會把我們帶出一個項目編號1
這時候就可以打上我們的文字
那如果我們需要項目編號2的話呢
就直接再按Enter
系统就会帮我们带出项目变号2了
那如果说我们今天想要分享的话呢
我们就再按一次Enter之后
系统会带出一个项目变号3
接着呢各位就可以透过上方的这个增加缩排的功能
点击进来之后呢
系统就会帮我们带出一个括号1
就可以再输入我们的文字了
再按Enter的话呢
系统就会带出一个括号2
那如果我們想要恢復到商議階層的話呢
我們就可以透過上方的這一個
減少縮排的功能
點擊這個減少縮排之後呢
系統他就會恢復到
項目編號3
所以這個就是我們說明的部分
說明呢各位可以透過這個增加縮排以及減少縮排的部分
後來進行調整
那如果說今天呢我們的功文比較簡單
只需要阻止
不需要說明的話呢
我們也可以透過
取消说明段落的部分
各位可以看到上张工具列
这边会有一个段落的功能
我们点击段落之后呢
这边会有一个说明段落
把它取消勾选
因为我们已经有内容了
所以系统就问我们说
是不是要一定移除我们的案确定
当时我们的说明段落就会取消了
那如果要恢复的话呢
一样点选段落里面的说明段落
那这个说明段落呢
就会再恢复了
好 那當我們的主旨說明都填寫完成之後呢
在下方這裡呢
會有一個正本以及副本還有操本的欄位
如果說我們今天這個公文要進行發文的話呢
我們就把滑鼠移到正本的地方
各位看到出現白色的小手之後呢
點擊進來
點擊進來之後呢
系統會帶出一個受文者設定的一個視窗
你就可以在上方这里呢
输入去输入我们的受文者
好那当我们输入受文者
如果有符合的资讯的话呢
下面就会有清单
我们就可以直接点击这个清单
系统就会帮我们把这个资料给带入了
那如果说我们除了正本之外
还有副本要输入的话呢
就可以在上方切換
切換到副本的頁先之後呢
一樣可以在這邊去進行受文者的輸入
好
那按Enter之後呢
系統就會幫我們把這個受文者的資訊給帶入囉
那我們除了自己手動輸入之外呢
我們也可以透過上方這邊會有一個常用通訊錄
好 點擊進來之後呢
我们系统都有提供一些
好像是中心的群组
那我们今天这个是测试机
资料比较少
各位在使用的时候
应该可以看到中心群组里面
会有不少的资料
那我们就可以直接点击
我们要的一个受文者的群组
点击之后呢
再按确定
那系统会问说因为这个是群组我们要不要进行展开那如果说我们不要讓它展開的話呢我們就按否那各位就可以看到我們這邊就會帶出我們的受文者的一個群組囉
好
那當我們的受文者都設定好之後呢
我們就按儲存
再按確定
這樣子我們的受文者資料
這部分的受文者資料就會帶入囉
好那接著再往下看
就是我們的一個署名
以及稿署名的部分
那因为我们学校在发文的时候呢
有些公文会需要设定署名以及稿署名
那设定的部分呢
我们就可以直接把滑鼠移到这个稿署名的部分点击好
点击进来之后
如果说我们的预设资料有去设定稿署名以及署名的话呢
都可以在这边点选下拉选单
稿署名的部分呢
就是校长的权衔
好了
再来就是校长的姓氏以及圈圈
那署名的部分呢
就是校长的权衔
再就是校长的全名
这样进行设定
临选好之后呢
再按确定
那当时我们在印证试函的时候呢
就可以看到有我们的属灵的资料咯
接着再往下
就是我们的会办单位的部分了
如果说今天这个公文啊
需要进行会办的话呢
我们就点击会办单位的栏位
点击进来之后呢
接着下方这边都有提供新单
我们就可以去点击
我们要汇办的一些单位
那上方这边的汇办方式呢
有依序汇办以及平行汇办
预设是在平行汇办
那各位可以依照我们自己的需求
来做修改
那我们点选完成之后呢
接着再按这个箭头的图示
那系统就会帮我们要汇办的单位呢
给从左边代入到右边
那我们再按确定
各位可以看到我们这边
就会有个汇办单位的资讯咯
好
那最后呢
是我们的一个觉醒层级的部分
除了直接从稿面上点之外呢
各位也可以看到我们左侧
这边会有一个觉醒层级的栏位
点击进来之后呢
去选择我们这份公文要觉醒的层级
第一层就是我们的校长
第二层呢
就是我们的单位的主任
选择好之后呢
当然完成
好
这样子我们的文稿呢
就算编辑完成咯
记得再稍微浏览一下内容有没有错误
需不需要进行调整
如果都没有任何问题的话呢
我们就可以点选左上方的储存
这个整红色磁碟片的图示
点了储存之后呢
系统会显示储存成功
那它会显示在哪边呢
它就会显示在我们左侧的草稿夹里面
如果说我们今天这个公文呢
打完之后还没有要取号
只是暂时先存起来的话呢
那它就會顯示在我們左側的草稿夾
我們就可以進到這邊呢
來找到我們剛剛存範檔的這一份公文
那如果說我們這個公文呢
後續會很常用到的話呢
那建議各位可以點選檔案的
定存心檔把它存成我的範本
那後續我們要辦這類型公文的時候呢
就可以快速的把這個範本給叫出來
來做利用
好
那以上呢
这个就是我们的一个公文制作的一个栏位编辑的操作方式咯
好我们这边呢
用简报再帮各位复习一下
回到我们简报的画面
那我们刚刚一开始有提到咯
文稿是采用名字画的方式